两个现在都是二婚之前都没有孩子。然后现在我们结婚之后，有一个男孩是两岁三个月。我这几年一直没上班，在家带孩子。然后他爷爷奶奶年龄大了我之前是上班一个月也就两三千块钱，是幼师。他之前也是两三千。然后在孩子半岁的时候，也就是一年半之前，他的工资涨到了，扣掉保险，嗯，全部给我，也就是4000或者4000多一点，我们的矛盾就是他脾气不太好，然后有点暴躁。每次发作的时候就是什么都不顾，有时候还会给我家里打电话骂。就是他每次抱的时候我就不敢动，就像老鼠见了猫一样，就那样很害怕，就怕他做出一些出格的事情。然后有时候还会就让在孩子两岁呃两个月的时候，有一次，他也是发脾气，抱了，然后他就抱着孩子就要跑，大冬天就要走。然后抱的时候也会带我走，我都不敢动。
我也不敢激怒他，然后我跟他父母的关系也不太好。因之前在一起住的时候，他妈妈经常就是瞪我。然后我们两个一有矛盾，他就他妈妈就我婆婆就瞪我，然后说一些很恶意的话。然后但是表面上在她面前还是挺好的。现在我的问题就是我想分开。然后年前年后我们爆发过一次，是因为他请一个同事来家里吃饭喝酒，然后我在客厅孩子的衣服打湿了，然后我在客厅给孩子擦身体，然后他就用眼瞪我，使劲瞪，就是那种很恶意的瞪我老公去上厕所，我同事说让我去热饭热主食，不喝了。我说那你们还喝吗？不喝我就去热馒头了。我我老公又从厕所出来，就听见我这样说，好像就是你在赶别人走的意思，然后也又瞪我人。然后过了他们走了，那个同事走了之后，我老公就对我爆发了，然后闹得很大，给我哥打电话，然后我哥来接我，然后他电话里对我哥大吼大叫的，反正就是当时他就是不控制了，不控制脾气，他也不是这意思，经常这样。嗯，然后，我们商量的就是，年前年后这段时间，就是分开。我现在的问题就是，我放不下孩子，因为。
孩子从小就一直跟着我了，没有离开过我。然后他的要求就是离婚可以，就是不给我探视权，不允许我探视。因为我看孩子在他的思想里面，就是我探视会带给孩子一些不好，对孩子会有一些影响。再一个就是，要么就跟他凑合过，就这两个，要么就分分开，就不给我探视权。这两个我都有点接受不了，主要是放不下孩子。
我现在不知道该怎么办，然后我也是这两天考虑了很很多很多，就是在同一个小县城，就假设分开了之后，你俩相隔多远呢？
不远，嗯，也就几公里，就这个男孩儿现在才两岁多，你是怎么考虑的呢？我不能带着他，我如果我带着他的话，我给不了他很好的，但是养活他是没问题，因为他父母有退休金，然后孩子爸爸也能挣钱，也能四四五千块钱。然后我呢，啊，我每个月也就是嗯，按之前正常的话，也就两三千块钱，就是能力也没有特别强，嗯，是是这样啊，就是关于孩子贪视权这个问题啊，这不是他说了算的。他不让我写到那个协议书里面，他也不允许我去看，他就是就很明确的这样说。这个不是他，他说怎么样就怎么样，大不了咱们就走程序呗，该怎么判怎么判呗。我感觉他可能就是逼你，他可能实际上是嗯不想跟你分开。跟你分开了之后，对吧，没有免费的保姆了，那他的日子叫什么？生活水平肯定得下降呀，他其实是不想跟你分开，所以他才那么逼你。但是我跟他，我一直在忍，一直在忍受，因没啊，我没有劝和的意思，我的意思就是让你知道他的真实的目的是什么。那我如果真的放下孩子，然后我这样走，我怎么能嗯，完全的就是放下孩子呢，就是。
不能说服我自己呢，不能说服不了。这是我们女人那个造物主给我们女人的身体里面有一个开关。这个开关一旦打开的时候，你是关不上的。你说龙飞姐有什么办法可以让我以后就不想孩子了，就不牵挂孩子了，我就能够决绝的就走了。我觉得做不到，绝大部分人做不到，除非那种很极极少数的人，他的那个身体构造，或者那个精神构造，跟我们正常人不一样的人，他能做到。
就是那种无良症，他能做到无良症，他不光能做到对孩子没牵挂，他连自己的孩子都可以啊。但是我们普通人啊，就是平凡的人，我们是做不到的。我感觉就是该怎么着怎么着，你得硬气。本来咱自己也能挣钱养活自己，是吧，也没有靠你，什么也没有吃，你什么也没有穿，你什么也没有依附，你什么就凭什么自己窝窝囊囊的呢？就得硬气，凭什么你不让我看孩子，我就不看孩子了？你算老几啊？就是那个探视权上面他不让我写，我怕到时候我没法就是通过法律嗯治他啊，不写他。如果没有明确的写说你放弃探视权这个事儿，如果探视权这个事儿压根不提，那你就是有另外，我还想问一个东西，就是我自己就是离开他之后，我我知道我的我的那个认知很低，然后情商也不高。我怎么能提升自己呢？就是我这些年，嗯，无论是工作上还是生活中，我都吃了很多苦，就是嗯，受了很多打压。
我就是怎么能让自己以后能更好一点？你现在工作主要是做什么呢？我干了十多年的幼师，然后这个行业嗯也能干下去。只不过是现在年龄大了，然后我幼师证、资格证、小学资格证都有，这些都是自己考的姐妹啊，如果说咱干幼师一个月就挣3000块钱的话，真不如去给人家当育儿嫂。当育儿嫂，真的收入比干幼师高很多。像北京、广州、上海、深圳这些地方，给人家当育儿嫂住家的育儿嫂的话，基本上就是8000好的。
1万多，你要是说你有那么好的经验啊，你给人家当个育儿嫂。你要是真心带孩子好，现在呃雇主也非常聪明，雇主在家里都是装监控的。雇主要是觉得你带孩子带的好，不舍得你离开的话，他就是就是得给你待遇给到位。
真的，当幼师不如干育儿嫂，不如干住家的育儿嫂。当然，这事儿也是拼缘分啊。你要遇到好一点的雇主，不会出那些乱七八糟的事儿。遇到好的雇主的话，在雇主家里的存纯攒钱，因为钱，你钱花不出去，基本上吃的住的用的都是雇主家里的，你的钱是花不出去的。纯攒钱啊。但是这事儿，你真的得用心，你发自内心的对孩子好，发自内心的对吧？为孩子考虑，你又有经验，然后又有这些知识在。
这明明挺嗯，我现在是嗯真的要就是放弃孩子，还是跟他打打官司争一争这个抚养权呢？你娘家能帮衬上吗？我父母可以看，他父母倒是看不了，因为他父母年龄大了，但是他父母有退休金，我妈也我父母也有退休金，但他们的思想观念就是看到孩子就像看到孩子爸爸一样，就是心里面。
没有看到自己孙子那样的那那种亲切我自己能感受到。如果我非要争抚养权，如果能到我手里，我父母也也愿意给我看，只不过是他们看到我的孩子就是像看到我现在老公一样。这事儿也看孩子，孩子性格怎么样啊？孩子是属于那种呃容易歇斯底里的哭喊闹脾气很倔呀，孩子还是属于那种乖乖巧巧的比较能亲人的这东西，养一养时间长了他就是有跟孩子的性格也有关系。现在孩子我一直带着，我看他性格也挺好，也挺温顺，就是一讲道理，他都能听得懂，什么都能懂啊。就是那如果说爸爸妈妈能带孩子本身又很乖又很温顺的话，孩子带久了之后人就是会改观的，就是会有感情的，嗯，那我知道了，谢谢，嗯，谢谢啊，拜拜。这个事儿你就别说亲爷爷啊，亲奶奶，你就算是做育儿嫂，你孩子如果很就是人孩子本身性格很好，你带久了都会有感情的，都会慢慢就喜欢上了，慢慢就真心发自内心的就爱了。别说是亲爷爷亲奶奶哦哦，亲外婆亲外公，别说是亲人，就算是没有血缘关系，这孩子会走路啦，会笑了，会干嘛干嘛啦，有的时候孩子会逗趣儿啦。
待久了他都会有感情的啊。